[Music]
you're leaving II yeah
is that true that yeah you're good
you're leaving II yeah I'm firing you
you're not retiring you're not gonna
retire well I don't know I'm just I'm
just I'm done that with that show no I
just you know I have to move on I get
very bored I've been there a long time
so long seven great years I had a great
time but I'm ready to take a little bit
of a break now there's this rumor that
you're gonna do a Netflix here I haven't
made any decisions about what I'm doing
everything and that's printed about me
is a lie
really yes okay I will tell you I don't
do any career decisions without
confronting or consulting what this is
gonna pop open no no it's just looking
me in the eye his belly button staring
at me in the eye
in case the interview lags that'll be
this many in many interviews when it
starts to sag he fires a button across
my bow yeah and that's when I know to
pick things up yeah is it true that
you're also considering you're
considering radio or is everything just
so that's an option honestly you know
what it's like you leave a job and other
people come to you and say do you want
to do this or this and I'm like I don't
know I want to go to Spain do you want
you want to go to Spain I mean I want to
go and like live I want to go to a land
where people don't matter
sounds like Game of Thrones it must be a
land where Lannisters rule a land with
Dragons no I want to go to a place where
people don't men don't understand what
I'm saying
a land where men don't understand what
saying like like I want to I want to
side you're there right now
[Laughter]
[Applause]